let's go next to our caller from the
three three six area code who's calling
today from three three six hey James
what's going on take me out to the game
I do have a question I had to say that
yeah very good uh what political sources
do you check yourself for you mean for
researching things for the show or in my
personal life oh well a little bit of
both before your show okay we tend to
cite the sources we use if you look at
the YouTube clips in the description
we'll put our sources there but they
range widely I mean you know everything
from the standard you know the top
investigative publications like the
Washington Post and New York Times we
will look at opinion pieces we'll look
at you know the Atlantic we will look at
local news when the story warrants I
mean it's a really wide list you know we
tend not to and I can't think of us
having done this for a long time we
don't use Fox News as a source
we don't use RT as a source we don't use
al Jazeera as a source I'm trying to
think of others but I mean it's a very
wide list of sources we use okay well I
was just curious about that
cuz you're one source you know I've got
to narrow it down myself well here's the
thing here's the really important thing
we try if when we're doing we always try
to go to the original source for any
story and if it's an opinion piece the
sources whoever has the opinion but when
it's a story about something that
happened oftentimes you'll see an
article that is really really really
work that someone else did which is
resizing the work that someone else that
we try to always go to the original
source to be able to very clearly say
here is what is being asserted let's
discuss whether we buy it okay well I
was just curious I appreciate it
all right James great to hear from you
appreciate the phone call very much